hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game that features a queen
sacrifice in merely 15 moves and the
opening is of course the London system
now I'm sure you guys either you play
the London system or you uh hate playing
against the London system either way you
need to see this game and you need to
know it uh because the moves that are
played here are fairly standard moves
and you uh could easily encounter them
in even bullet or Blitz Games online so
you should definitely know this it was
played in a match in the metropica in
the match between Slovakia and Croatia
representing Slovakia on board one is
yet we've seen a couple of his games
already on the channel and representing
Croatia on board one Malad and Palette
so let's dive straight into it it's uh
it's definitely something that you
should know so here uh year which opens
with D4 we have Knight to F6 Knight to
F3 D5 and now Bishop to F4 the London
system is on the board and if you're
wondering uh why I'm not showing a World
Series championship game today is
because today is the rest day if you
guys remember we have two games of play
then one rested and to get some played
and rested into and so on and so on so
uh tomorrow we will be having the
world's championship game and here uh C6
is the uh pretty standard reply E6 is
the top move C5 is the second most
popular option so this is all very nice
we have E3 and now Ponte E6 now this is
quite rare usually uh players uh go
Knight to the C6 or queen to B6 but E6
is also uh very much played even though
much less but it has been played against
uh dingler and karwana kariakin played
at um Nakamura played it interestingly
they all played it against Magnus cost
and as Magnus is also a fan of the
London system uh C3 and not Knight B to
D7 again Knight to C6 the more popular
option I'd beat the D7 fairly rare
Knight beat the D2 and now Bishop to E7
so why doing the standard the setup the
the pawns and dark squares your light
score Bishop can go in between the
bishop on F4 the Knight will come to E5
where you will Castle King said he will
push F4 you will bring the Rook over to
F3 to G3 or th3 and create a sort of a
standard attacking pattern and black
needs to figure out a way how to defend
against all of this sunlight the E5 and
usually you don't want to trade uh when
a white plays Knight D5 but here it's
actually the best move Knight captures
an E5 and now Bishop captures an e5d
captures would be perhaps a bit too
ambitious because after let's say Knight
to D7 you can go Bishop to D3 and yes
your position looks very nice even the
queen can come to H5 but black will just
ignore you black will not Castle King
side let's say Knight to F3 you need to
defend the pawn here Rook to B8 then B5
is coming so I don't know it seems like
a like a very offbeat way to play this
so Bishop captures an E5 makes more
sense here we have Bishop to D7 and now
uh there are a couple of games for
Bishop to D3 was played but here we have
Pawn to A4 just stopping B5 and it is
not as of move 9 then we have a
completely new game so Bishop to C6 the
bishop now assumes this diagonal and the
bishop to D3 by ergos with Bishop to D6
the pilots could also Castle here he
decides to trade off the dark Square
Bishops first but now as we advertised
upon the F4 so you know that if Bishops
are traded You're Gonna Play F
characters and E5 and now let's in
Knight T4 Queen to G4 and already you
are you are facing some difficulties
here the Knight is attacked three times
the G7 Pawn is hanging so it's not it's
not ideal so instead after I have four
ballads just castled here and here a
year which also castles Marvin goes by a
queen to E7 connects the Rooks and now
Rook the F3 so a standard rock lift um
yeah you might see in the London system
nothing out here and here your spidey
sense should really uh go off like there
is danger here and you should play
something like Knight to E4 and okay
white could play something like Rook to
H3 but you're gonna trade let's say
Bishop captures they have captures
You're Gonna Play H6 and everything is
perfectly fine if white ever trades this
Pawn is um most of the times never a
problem here it's a very very hard for
white to actually go after it and it
will uh stifle blacks uh White's pieces
a little bit so instead after Rook to F3
G6 was played and yes is only move 13
and here Rook the H3 and getting The
Rook into the attack and here you you if
your spidey sense wasn't going off on
the previous move now it should be just
screaming uh because here Bishop
captures an E5 is a must however Knight
the D7 was played now threatening to
pick up the bishop with the Knight but
now the com the game is completely
winning for the air gusher so feel free
to pause the video and to win the game
for the Argos uh well I give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
beautiful uh Queen sacrifice and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is of course queen queen to H5
I'm even gonna do it in slow motion
because there is no defense against
Queen captures on H7 there's just
nothing you can do oh okay the obvious
thing is that we can capture the queen
but it doesn't help so congratulations
to everyone who found this I'm sure
you're not even watching the video
anymore you're off to leeches or
chess.com trying to pull this off and
I'm sure you're gonna be able to do it
but if uh G captures on H5 then Rook the
G3 check only one move for black queen
G5 and this is not Checkmate as the
bishop controls the dark squares The
Rook delivers check and you might be
wondering but what if we don't capture
the queen but what else is there how do
you defend against Queen captures on H7
Checkmate you could uh you you could
let's say move the Rook let's say you
move the Rook somewhere it doesn't help
just Queen captures an H7 and after King
to f8 it's still Checkmate Queen to h8
or you could try Pawn to F6 or Point F5
doesn't really matter okay now the black
queen guards the H7 Pawn but now Bishop
captures on D6 you just win a piece and
again black has to resign yeah again you
can't capture back because of Checkmate
and if you capture uh the White Queen
then Bishop captures Queen attacks the
rook and once The Rook moves you're just
gonna pick up the pawn and you are up a
full Bishop as you can see uh White has
a dark Square Bishop black does not so
you are you know just completely
completely winning here so incredible as
it is uh something like this can happen
in a classical game between two grand
Masters and uh it's important to notice
like I said even if you enjoy playing
the London or you have struggle or
you're struggling to play against the
London uh this is something that you
should know as it uh definitely could
happen to you but Queen the H5 such a
classy weight in the game I'm very happy
that I was able to show this game and uh
especially now on the rest day from the
wheelchair championship match uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
I would like to thank yaroslav
Philip Dennis said Borgo and James
Cashman for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions such as
this one uh and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and go try and pull this off
uh I mean yeah that that is why we are
here see you soon